hello freak [ __ ] so organize this
like yet because it's run by you know
Capo's all over the city you know every
ward had its capo and yes sir cago has
this uniquely violent history and even
to this day
you mean with with what's going on the
Southside with all the gang vibe it's
it's it's shocking to me as somebody who
was born in Chicago I still live in
Chicago that it's just like we've
normalized this insane violence yeah in
our kid in this community you know who
don't even realize I think most people
have no idea how much gun violence goes
I heard the other day I could I could be
wrong and I'm sure he can find but I
think somebody said the other day
there's been 3700 shootings in Chicago
already this year and I think we're
already over six hundred gun fatalities
and this is it like every year now Wow I
mean I just an even Trump at some point
floated out like maybe they should bring
the National Guard I wish they would do
something I just such a dissonant
raggedy that just keeps going and
nothing seems to happen
yeah and it seems to have a lot of
momentum behind it like the murders
they've they make people have revenge
murders and then it just piles on top of
each other and it doesn't seem like
there's any any stopping inside well
here's the thing and you know this is
the classic tale now there was reporting
the other day that the carjackings in
Chicago have gone up like 200% and now
those carjackings are filtering into the
nice neighborhoods so now you're gonna
start seeing some action because now
it's now it's blowing up past the sort
of you know I mean look at that the shot
clock a person is shot every two minutes
and 20 seconds a person is murdered
every 12 hours
Oh two hours and 20 minutes a person is
murdered every 12 hours and 23 minutes
that's a lot wow I'm it's my home and I
just you know I have a guy that I met
when I was down there he's a driver he
drove us around and he was saying that
he used to be a cop and that what
happened was they arrested some of the
top level drug dealers I've heard this
exact same story and as soon as they did
that there became this power vacuum
yeah for years I I got a little inside
information for years what I'd heard is
that they had this sort of like as long
as you stay on this side of the street
will kind of you know will look the
other way for this but you got to keep
your people in line over here right and
I know enough people in the PD that that
was sort of the general understanding
like even like I'm ever one time because
I knew somebody worked in the in the in
like the gang task force I was like how
come there's always Horrors on the
bridge on Friday night like don't you
guys see the 50 [ __ ] on the bridge and
they said no we debts where we tell all
the [ __ ] to go so we can protect them
we'd rather have them there so we can
keep an eye on them and we know what's
gonna happen anyway so better we control
it right so that was the way Chicago
sorta operated was like we're tolerate
crime up to this level and twice a year
we'll run everybody and just to kind of
make the make it look good in the paper
and then apparently whatever they did
that created this power vacuum that's
just what I've heard I don't know it was
a former cop and the way he was
describing was pretty absolute he's like
they made a mistake they you know this
solution that you were saying of like
kind of like saying hey keep it over
here wraps and we'll arrest a certain
amount of people it sounds like maybe
that's the only way to manage it well
yeah the one thing I have heard from
people that were are in those
communities is that literally the and
this maybe supports what you're saying
is that the the power divisions are like
block to block so it's almost like an
insurgency where it's like two blocks
versus two blocks versus one block
versus three blocks so literally if
you're walking on the wrong side of the
street it's not even like neighborhood
the neighborhood it's like block to
block yeah which is crazy I'm just
growing up in that neighborhood having
that be your normal as a child and then
you know growing into adulthood around
that and having just used to people
getting shot used to shooting people you
mean if there's that many people getting
shot and that many gunshots going off
everybody must be common I mean it must
be common everyone yeah I don't know
it's just crazy that's just the heart
breaking it's such a unique town - it's
an amazing city it really is yeah I mean
we we have this weird bare-knuckle
history yeah and it's still there you
no no amount of yuppies moving and has
changed as sort of working-class sort of
ethos
[Applause]
[Music]